I'm Carole Kushnir. I'm from California and I'm
here representing being identified with the BRCA2 Mutation.
>> tyk can you tell us a little bit more what,
what is the BRCA2 mutation you have and what does it mean?
>> Well I have the one mutation is. that was tested and reported is,
6 1 7 4 delT and it is a
pretty common mutation in Ashkenazi Jewish people. And an
uncle of mine is also, has the same mutation. And my cousin, his daughter.
>> When did you find out you had the mutation?
>> I found out in early 2010.
>> Okay.
>> And, it was a surprise.
I did the 23andMe, genetic testing and
the results came back and it was. Surprising.
>> And what did they tell you it means, what, like when you
have this mutation, what does it mean, what does, for you, for an individual.
>> Well, the risk of breast cancer is increased compared to the
general population, and the risk of ovarian cancer is increased. Did
you know what those increased risks were, what those percentages were?
>> Well, for the breast cancer risk it's
between 20 and 50% risk. Although, I saw a higher number
earlier when I looked recently, it seems like the risk. The number I saw
changed, and for ovarian cancer, the risk is much
lower but the risk is higher than in the general population. And you can also
calculate the risk based on age. So compared to the general population.
The risk for breast cancer at my age, at 70, is four,
about 4.5 out of the 100 compared to about 2.5 out of 100 for another woman at
age 70 who does not have the BRCA mutation.
>> I see. And what did you think about this whole. Sort
of probability issue, you know, the idea of a percentage I mean, I
think a lot of people think genetics is going to tell them. Oh, I
am or I'm not going to have this trait. What was running through
your mind?
>> A lot.
[LAUGH].
I am married to a physicist who understands. Statistics. And
he must have explained this to me half a dozen times.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> And all I could focus on was the, the
high number. But, of course, as you get older the risk,
it changes, it varies. Assuming that there are a hundred people.
Uh,100 women with the BRCA mutation, and 50
already, 50 out of 100 have already had breast
cancer, then the statistics change. And I can't really explain
it but um,it is daunting to think that there is.
You know, double the risk of someone else my
age, even if it is a low number. However, if
you have the mutation there's, as far as I understand
it, there's, in my particular case I'm missing the T.
[LAUGH].
>> Mm-hm. And, the whole
gene shifts. The BRCA gene is shifting and there is a
mutation. And so, it's not operating correctly is, is my best understanding.